[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
hey everyone
good to see you all it's been a few
weeks since we've had one of these live
sessions so thanks for tuning in
as you know from the alert that you got
however you got it through i don't know
email twitter facebook
youtube alert of some sort i don't know
we are having a conversation
today with nobel laureate paul nurse who
uh
brilliant biologist geneticist
he has a new book we're going to be
talking about that book that book is
called what is life
some of you may know that a physicist
named irwin schrodinger wrote a book of
the same title back in the 1940s
schrodinger as we know of course is one
of the vital thinkers
in the development of quantum mechanics
and i might mention that this year right
2021 is a special anniversary
year it's a banner year for quantum
mechanics
the famous double slit experiment of
davidson and germa
the inklings of that experiment began
in 1921 and 1921
speaking of nobel laureates in addition
to paul nurse albert einstein of course
was also nobel laureate and einstein won
the 1921
nobel prize in physics he was a he
actually received the award
in 1922 so sometimes people get a little
confused by that but officially
it was 1921 nobel prize
and what did he win the nobel prize for
this group of course knows the answer to
that yes the general person
what did einstein win the nobel prize
for most people say oh of course it was
relativity
they don't actually specify which
relativity of course 1905 was the
special theory
1915 1916 was the general theory
but as you all know of course
einstein did not win the nobel prize for
relativity one of her
quantum mechanics were more precisely
for the photoelectric effect the
explanation of the photoelectric effect
which many people look at
that explanation is one of the key
moments
some people say the first moment in the
development of
quantum mechanics so we will be having a
number of programs
celebrating this anniversary of quantum
mechanics
many of you have asked me when i'm going
to come
out with the quantum mechanics course
that will be a partner with the
course on special relativity that's on
world science u it's on now
youtube we for a long time only had that
available in sort of a dark
corner of the world science u website
people weren't aware that
it was there for the most part so we put
out the special relativity course
as you know in two versions we put out a
two and a half hour non-mathematical
version
we put out an 11 and a half hour
mathematical
version yeah it's been kind of
gratifying you know get that material
out there the uh
the non-math version i don't know a
little less intimidating
now we put that out in early august now
so i don't know it's about six months
ago
got about two million views so you folks
and others seem to appreciate
the approach that world science festival
has taken
to having a more formal presentation
still informal because it's me i'm
always kind of informal but a more
formal presentation
of the ideas of of einstein and so many
of you have been
writing to me because a long time ago
when we first made
that material i said i was going to do
one on special relativity
on general relativity and on quantum
mechanics
so rightly you have said where's the
quantum mechanics course
sorry been busy these things are not
easy to put together
but we are now starting in
on the quantum mechanics course so there
will be a
highly visual non-mathematical version
for those of you who just like the ideas
and want the ideas to wash over you and
there will be a mathematical version
for those who really want to to dig in
and i don't know if i should probably
say this but whatever
the quantum course i mean i've been
thinking about it in this context
the world science youth context for a
long time and i've been trying it out at
columbia
the methodology at least so i've sort of
tuned it up see what students understand
what they don't understand so that
course will be equivalent to
what i teach at columbia university
so you know i don't know if it's gonna
be free it's got i guess it kind of has
to be free i don't know it's kind of
weird
so much effort and so much so much
financial resource i have to tell you
goes behind the filming of these things
the creating of the animation so if any
of you are flush
right if any of you are flushing can
help support that activity
then we can keep it free so i don't know
i think there's a button somewhere in
the world science festival website so
anybody feeling generous uh we would be
enormously
thankful for any support you can give on
this let me just take a
a couple questions and give a little
preamble to the
material that we'll be talking about
here today
let me see what you guys are asking
here's one from
raghav anand what are the similarities
between
original matter which we see around us
against familiar matter
and dark matter what are the
similarities well
the only similarity that we can point to
with confidence
is that ordinary matter and dark matter
both
when you have ingredients
of either sort that give rise to a
gravitational field
they tug on other material objects
in fact that's of course how we know
that there is dark matter or at least i
really should say to be more precise
that's the evidence that we have
suggesting that there is
dark matter dark matter is not the only
possible
explanation for the observations but
when we look at the
motion of stars and galaxies the motion
of galaxies that motion cannot
be accounted for if the only
gravitational force
operating on those objects comes from
the matter that we can see
that's the original matter ra gabanand
is referring to the
familiar matter it has to be other stuff
that doesn't give off light
and that stuff that doesn't give off
light is dark matter the dark matter
gives rise to the force of gravity but
the similarities could end there at
least in principle
i mean there are candidates for the dark
matter that are ordinary depending on
exactly how
broad your definition of ordinary is it
could be
collections of black holes it's a
possible explanation
kind of a dark horse dark horse
explanation for dark matter but
dark matter could also be less familiar
particles a leading candidate for a long
time but
now it's under some experimental
pressure
are particles known as wimps all right
you know of wimps weakly
interacting massive particles
so these are are they ordinary
not really in the sense of we don't see
them in the stuff
around in the environment tables and
chairs
planets and people are not directly made
of wimps
but these particles fit into a version
of the standard model of particle
physics
critical physics it's a natural
candidate and you may recall from our
conversation with
frank wilczyk when was that i don't know
three weeks ago i think maybe three
weeks ago now yeah
we had a conversation with frank
wilcheck and frank put forward this
idea of the axion this
hypothetical particle that emerges from
other considerations not from dark
matter considerations rather
a particle that emerges to resolve
certain questions
having to do with the strong nuclear
force and that could be a dark matter
particle as well and again i wouldn't
call that ordinary
matter in the language that raghav is
using
it's pretty exotic so so the differences
can be substantial between ordinary and
dark matter here's another
question i see well let me grab it
before it scrolls away
oh i think i got it prom virac
prom prom sorry vrak to professor green
yes that's me
does life need to have some physical
reality yeah that's
relevant to the conversation today does
life need to have some physical reality
as far as we know it does i am of a
materialist
physicalist perspective i suspect that
paul nurse
is as well but maybe we'll probe
his views on that in our discussion but
a physicalist
perspective envisions that
life and even mind are nothing but
collections of material particles
arranged in a particular organized
manner
allowing for the basic processes
of life to take place and those basic
processes while paul
nurse will discuss his view of what is
life but
just to tip his hand a little bit since
i've read his book i've got the
punchline already in mind
he does come down with a physicalist
perspective as he'll discuss
where life is
any system that can carry out certain
processes among those processes are the
processes of
evolving information processing
as we will see and so from that
perspective it's hard to imagine
life via that definition existing
without
a physical form without physical reality
but look
we don't know everything you know
sometimes people get a little bit
i don't know if irritated is the right
word it's probably too strong they
they they wonder in conversation with me
whether i'm too open-minded
about things that science typically
issues ignores tries to cross
off the list of things that we
coherently talk about
but the bottom line is i don't know what
happens when we die
i think we're just gone i think it's
like pulling the plug on a computer
i think the processes that define life
simply stop and that's it
but who knows and you know oftentimes
to hedge my bed i mean i sometimes worry
that
it's the very people who think that way
that when they die the plug is pulled
so just to hedge the bets
i don't know maybe there is something
else
i don't think so but i don't know so
it's a good question
and one that we cannot fully answer
as yet but we will ask paul his view
on that in fact in his book he has a
nice moment where
he's talking about his own brush
recently with his own mortal
nature and how that can infect
the way one thinks about their life so
whether or not
one's views allow for an afterlife
confronting one's own mortality can have
a deep impact
on the way one thinks about the world
all right so just a couple minutes of
preamble introduction to the kinds of
ideas that we're going to be talking
about here today
look if you think about life and i'm
going to jump right off
of proom's question if you think about
life
as a certain kind of physical system you
still
even in that physicalist perspective
face
a number of deep questions and one deep
question is
how does the existence of life square
with the second law of thermodynamics
and in fact
in the earlier book called what is life
written by
schrodinger that is what schroedinger
was worried about
not not completely but some of the later
chapters focused on this question and
and schroedinger
schroedinger came to this notion that
yeah
understanding entropy and life is a
conundrum
really worth thinking about because look
entropy what is the idea the entropy is
an amount of
it's a calculation of the amount of
disorder in a physical system and
a physicist named ludwig boltzmann gave
us
the answer to how you do that
calculation in fact
he loved the answer he was so wedded to
the answer he was so
proud of the answer he saw that answer
as his legacy perhaps he saw that answer
as his
answer to his own mortal nature that he
chiseled
the result into his tombstone right so
here's a little
image i think we have there it is
there's boltzmann's
grave i believe that's in vienna i could
be wrong don't hold me to that i think
it's true but maybe not but look at the
top there you see that formula at the
top
that's boltzmann and s equal k log
w he chiseled the formula for entropy
into his tombstone
you know my tombstone will probably say
i don't know
loving father hopefully i'm
i assume i'm going to outlive my wife
she's extremely
robust in the sense of any illness seems
to just
bounce off her i have to ask paul nurse
about that she's got this
mega powerful immune system so i think
my
wife will outlast me maybe she'll put on
the tombstone
you know loving husband i don't know i'm
just sort of setting it up right now
but boltzmann on his tombstone just has
s equal k log w and in that formula s is
entropy
k is a constant that we call boltzmann's
constant and
log is the logarithm mathematical
operation and w
counts the number of
microstates compatible with a given
macro state
so you look at the world around you and
has certain macroscopic properties like
the air in this room has a certain
pressure temperature and volume
boltzmann said if you count the number
of rearrangements of the microscopic
ingredients compatible with those macro
parameters take the logarithm multiplied
by k that gives you the amount of
disorder that gives you the entropy and
he and others were able to establish
that entropy
has an overwhelming tendency to increase
disorder tends to increase the number of
rearrangements of the ingredients
available tend to increase but living
systems
seem to thwart this drive toward
ever greater disorder and that's
what schrodinger was concerned about and
the answer he came to he framed it in a
unusual language that has created some
kind of confusion over the years
over the decades now he wrote that book
back in the 40s
he wrote the book during world war ii in
fact
it's kind of amazing schroedinger i
think we have a picture of schroeder
he's kind of a wild man
do we have a shot of schrodinger that we
can sort of
bring out there he is i gotta get
i gotta get that outfit i gotta get
those shoes
i gotta get a photo like that
that is a photo so schrodinger
wild man that he was in fact there are
wild aspects of his personal life that i
that i won't get into now because it's a
family audience
suffice to say he had
non-singular tastes in
the environment that made him most happy
and um and uh yeah so he went to ireland
and in the midst of world war ii
he gives these lectures on what is life
and the people that come out to the
lectures it was stunning
high government officials large public
audiences would gather
to hear a physicist schroedinger talk
about life
and one of the issues was how does life
apparently
thwart the second law of thermodynamics
and schrodinger gave the answer in terms
of what he called
negative entropy negative entropy
and what he really meant by negative
entropy is that we living systems
we take in from the environment highly
ordered
structures food plants
things that our bodies can then use as
fuel and release the
resulting entropy from bodily processes
to the environment so we
take in low entropy and we give off high
entropy that's really what he meant
by negative entropy i've sort of given
this my own little name is called
i called the entropic two step right
what's the two-step right you take in
low entropy
step one you release high entropy step
two and living systems are able to dance
that two-step
and we dance it as long as we live and
when we no longer are living
then we can't dance the two-step and our
entropy
our order goes away we disintegrate
into a disordered structure and so that
was
schrodinger's answer to this issue of
how we can have living systems in a
universe headed toward ever greater
disorder
and it raises to a very precise
level the ways in which life can be
thought of as a physical system even our
brains right i mean we have this
nice little graphic here i think our
brains and our bodies
are nothing but collections of particles
that
for a while have a certain degree of
order and organization
and so these particles here they don't
seem to have any structure yet but if
you
arrange them if you organize them into
the right
configuration that's the kind of thing
that you can
get a human brain able to carry out
the kinds of things that our conscious
self-awareness is capable of
and so this way of thinking about things
yeah it's
very reductionist unabashedly
reductionist some people apologize for
their reductionist leanings i don't
because at one in the same time i
recognize that this is not the full
story
it is the deepest particulate account
of say what a brain ultimately
at rock bottom is but you have to layer
as we've discussed
previously and as i write about in my
own book until the end of time you have
to layer
story upon story above the reductionist
account so you understand the chemists
chemists i should say account the
biologist account the philosopher's
account
the neuroscientist account all of those
accounts
the artist's account they
allow us to have a fuller appreciation
of the question what is life
but at rock bottom
life is a physical system life is a
physical system governed by the laws of
physics
and that squarely points to this
perspective
again i'm open to other ideas but this
perspective squarely
imagines that there's no life
force this idea of vitalism that people
put forward a long time ago
there doesn't seem to be any need for it
and somebody there doesn't seem to be
any need for
conscious awareness to be anything more
than laws of physics playing them out in
a very particular structure called
the human brain so we'll be talking
about these ideas
with paul in just a couple of minutes
let me just take one more
question before we do that so yeah tim
greenglass says schrodinger did not like
cats yeah that's
that's another quirky quality but he
certainly made use of
cats to uh popularize
an issue i think it well actually it's
an interesting question i know
i'm not completely sure if it was if
schrodinger's cat
if it was schrodinger himself who used
the cat analogy
i think he did something in this chat
just tell me i believe that's correct
but if you ask me what the reference
or the source was i'm not completely
sure okay what else we have
um so ted says consciousness as a field
and the brain
as a medium yeah people do use that kind
of language but by feel do you mean
again a physical field like the
electromagnetic field sure then maybe
as long as it all fits within the rubric
of physics either as we currently
understand it or as one day we will
understand it
the issue that scientists often have
with that kind of talk and i've had that
kind of talk i mean a friend of mine i
haven't had
a conversation with him in a long time
but matthew ricard
he's a buddhist monk wrote a beautiful
book
called the monk in the philosopher a
kind of debate his philosophy his father
was a philosopher a french philosopher
real french philosopher i had a
conversation with him
once and uh he kind of had no time for
me
he had his views and would not think
about things in a different way but
anyway so matthew ricard
he thinks about consciousness in much
the same way that ted
m just described it that somehow there's
this consciousness field
as a fundamental substrate of reality
and somehow in a way that i don't really
understand
physical structures can tap into that
field and that's what
the brain is doing is that possible i
don't i don't know
i don't i don't see any need for that
but if you ask me
does science truly understand what
consciousness is
i think the state of the answer is quite
simple
no we don't i know maybe maybe when i
bring paul in he'll
correct me and tell us that now we have
fully unraveled
consciousness but i suspect that is
still an open question all right i see
that paul is in the waiting room so i'm
going to
switch over and let me just give you a
couple words
um paul he's a english geneticist former
president of the
royal society former president of
rockefeller university in new york which
is where
he and i first met some years ago
he's currently chief executive and
director of the francis crick
institute and he was awarded the 2001
nobel prize in physiology or medicine
for the discovery of protein
molecules that control the division of
cells in the cell
cycle he has also been in many world
science festival programs not
not a little while because he moved
it was great when we had him in new york
all to ourselves but he
he moved back to the uk he's also the
author of a new book
what is life that we will be talking
about and with that let me bring
sir paul nurse into our
conversation hey paul how are you hi
brian i like your background you have a
lot of snow there
yeah it's actually a real background so
you could think you know is it fake no
it's
there it is i don't you can hear the
solid window yeah we're up in um in the
catskill mountains where it just never
stops
snowing it's actually even maybe a
little too much at the moment well i'm a
bit jealous here am i in central london
and it's just gray and wet as usual yeah
yeah i remember that
all too well for my oxford days
35 years ago or so yeah no
but how are you how are you doing
through this uh this period of
strangeness in the world well it is a
bit strange but i have to say
i'm sitting in um the institute now
and we have been um very lucky because
we could had pcr testing
from march onwards and we've tested our
um colleagues and staff every week
now twice a week and so that's allowed
us to be
largely open for the entire period
sometimes we've reduced numbers the
infection rates are high in london at
the moment so
we reduced it to maybe half but it's
allowed us to be
active as a research institute all that
time
wow and i mean have you had any problems
because of that
we have not really i mean we've of
course have people who got infected
um infected from outside we've had
almost no transmission within the
institute
maybe over a period of nine months maybe
two
times possibly three because we were
sequencing
the virus so we knew that so actually
probably
this is the safest place in london i
would say because
we only let people in who have been
tested in the last three or four days
otherwise they can't come in and we've
managed to keep it a safe environment
any reason you don't do um the rapid
test
every day yes because they're not really
very reliable
i mean the tests we do are very reliable
if we get a positive we check it again
um at the same time so we we know we've
got a real positive so that
leaves uh false positives down one in
five thousand one in ten thousand
and the rapid the rapid the uh test just
cannot begin to match
that um right so when you do when you do
the pcr test
do you how long does it take to get the
result
we get it within 12 hours usually um
sometimes it may take depending on the
robots and
when the robots don't work and get
behaviors they should
um sometimes it might take 18 hours but
it's a turnaround in less than a day
wow well that's that's uh that is the
way to do it i absolutely agree
um so thanks for uh taking some time out
to speak with us i want to see
you brian yeah it's great to see you too
for some time really good to see you
yeah no i remember those times we would
join you in your office at rockefeller
university and just
have a tea and hang out no those are the
uh those are good
my office is much smaller now i did
notice
yeah i wasn't gonna say anything but i
did notice
you know that's what happens um but you
have this new book
beautiful new book let me make sure i
get in front of the screen here what is
what is life and we're gonna spend some
time talking about that but before we do
you mind if we just have a little um
it's often nice for
the audience here to get a sense of your
own personal
journey not to go into a fantastic
detail but uh
you know where you were born what your
interests were early on just to get the
ball rolling with that
yeah i'm very happy to do that well i'm
would you believe from my accent i come
from uk
i mean really um i was brought up in
london um i was brought up in a
non-academic family working class family
i was the only one in my family to stay
on at
school after age 15 got really
interested in science
quite early on mainly through uh you
would you believe
um astronomy physics and also
uh biology and natural history and um
managed to get into university took me
some time i wasn't great at examinations
and
i i had some difficulty getting in i
managed to fail a rather basic
examination
um which was required for all uh
entrance into
university which was a basic
qualification
in a foreign language yeah and i managed
to fail it uh
french six times it was a i think a
world record i think a world record but
anyway i went to university i don't know
i think a quick question on that so
so do you think this is a pet peeve of
mine do you think it's important
that graduate students have a
second language how vital do you think
that requirement is
i would love to have a second language
without anything
but honestly if it was demanded of me
i'd be um sweeping the streets right
right
right so you know let's put it in
context um
so yes i'd love it and yes of course
it's right to
expect um that type of breadth but
um i'm quite good at other things so
it's not that i'm completely hopeless
and everything else but not foreign
languages but presumably you failed it
because you didn't study hard
right i mean no no i studied so hard
brian you've got it all wrong
i really really tried and um and
for two two of those failures i i i
didn't have any other i was working as a
technician
in guinness brewery actually a brewery
that made beer
and that's my only task academically for
the entire year was to sit this
examination
and still manage to fail it twice
complete no hoper
but they'll let you in obviously at some
point yes they let me in
i um i i made a case and but they
they gave me one condition and the
condition was
i had to do french for one year at the
university
and this is quite entertaining i ended
up being allocated
one person in the class with the most
junior
french as assistant professor and i
remember sitting down
in front of him and he said paul you
don't want to be here
and i don't want to be here so we're
going to do a deal
and the deal is this uh at the end of
this i have to give you an
examination i'm going to give you 500
words of
scientific french to translate into
english
about a third of the words are in
english in the first place because it's
signed
right i'm allowed you to take i am
allowed the examiner to let you take any
book
into the um into the examination and i'm
going to allow you to take a dictionary
and i am going to guarantee that if you
just
look up every word and put it in
approximately the right
order i will pass you not well but i
will pass you
and i don't think we need to meet again
in the rest of this year that's been i
don't think it would happen
today though that is fantastic well look
it's
been uh it's it's humanity that
benefited from that
french teacher's generosity of spirit so
uh
we can't we can't uh fault him or her
for that
so so then you went to university and
and um
when did biology sort of grab you as
yeah it grabbed me really science
grabbed me and then
um i wasn't sure whether to go to
physics or
or biology my daughter one of my
daughters is a professor in physics
in geneva in the large hadron collider
and i
i could have perhaps gone in that
direction but what i thought was
um working at physics the problem seemed
so
big and in biology somehow the problems
were smaller
and as a consequence of that what i felt
is
maybe even if i wasn't great i could
make
some contribution to knowledge whereas i
wasn't sure
i could do that in physics so i went for
biology and
maybe that's even true because you know
we play around
biologists with smaller things and you
discover more about the smaller things
and it builds up
whereas when i look at my daughter and
you know this big problem of the
you know the basic nature of matter you
do feel a bit uncomfortable
in your stomach maybe you don't brian
but um
well that's the that's the allure of it
all
but then when you're actually in the
field you realize that most of the work
you do
is smaller even though it kind of slots
into those big
questions so maybe there's more
similarity than than difference
from a day-to-day perspective you know
it's hard to maybe you're right
maybe you're right yeah but you know
what i was doing i was wandering around
the garden
looking at where spiders webs were and
you know i'd make a little map and then
i could think why is the spider's web
here or there and it's a bit difficult
to think about bosons in one's back
garden in terms of experiments so yeah
right there's that difference too
there's there's no question about that
for sure um and then you uh you started
to
work on research projects oh yes yes yes
sorry we're back at university
i decided that i um wanted to work
i was interested in what life is and
we're going to talk a bit more about it
because i eventually wrote a book and i
thought
if i was interested in life i should try
and focus on the simplest
entity which unambiguously you could say
was alive
and and that is the cell and we i i'm
sure we'll discuss a little bit about
that
and so i decided i wanted to be a cell
biologist i decided i would use genetics
to take it apart
and then the question was during my phd
um what should i study i
studied something really rather dull if
i could be perfectly honest with you
it was um amino acid metabolism in in
fungi
i did a first degree in plant sciences
and
that taught me how to do experiments
it sounds a bit mundane but knowing what
a good experiment is
knowing what a controlled is knowing um
when you can interpret data
in particular ways all of this is
actually really important
yeah significant lessons and though
you're not discovering something great
about the universe you're discovering
how to
investigate the universe and with that
background
when i and i did that in in norwich it's
in
the east of england where i was born
actually i wasn't brought up there
um but where i was born and i then
decided
um what is an important question
in biology and it was thinking about
you know what is the difference between
something that's living and not living
and one of the characteristics
is the ability to reproduce right and
here am i interested in the cell and
reproduction
and then i thought how do cells
reproduce how do they control it
and i decided that in 21 22 and i stuck
with it prion
yeah and here i am half a century nearly
later
and i'm still working at that same
problem
yeah well i mean it's great i mean you
know uh
i mean einstein wanted to know the
unified theory and he stuck with it for
30 years
he didn't get anywhere you know so
you've gotten somewhere so
yeah a rather bigger problem though if i
may well you know
different problem a different problem
yeah so that um
that does take us to sort of the the
main
the main issues here of what is life
what can
life accomplish and um you know the one
thing i have to say quickly is i noticed
that
so here's here's your book and it's
beautiful
skinny book yeah about three weeks ago
we spoke to
your nobel laureate colleague in physics
frank wilcheck who
himself has another skinny book and i'm
starting to see a pattern that all you
nobel guys
have these really skinny books except
then i realized that kip
thorne wrote a book
and um you know gravitation and it's not
so skinny
so so maybe that's not the key i'm
starting to think that maybe uh
and roger penrose
they're pretty fat too yeah road to
reality is about
um not that thick yeah absolutely
now the other thing you know i noticed
obviously and you mention it of course
in the book is that the title is one
that has been used before erwin
schrodinger
wrote what is life in the 1940s or so
haldane js haldane wrote a version of
what is life at a
at a later time in fact i think we may
even have their uh
their book covers here so we can sort of
see the uh progression
there's that this is i have that i have
that one yeah
the distant and then haldane's version
you know and then
your version so do you see
this book following in
a recurring attempt by scientists to
try to answer this deep question like is
this a moment
where we now have learned enough to
reconsider
this deep question well
i tell you what i was trying to aim at
i i read a lot of popular science books
and what i began to notice is that the
books written by
physicists such as yourself
generally took on big questions
ones that we we struggled with and which
um
uh are go to the fundamental nature
of uh reality but often
biological popular books tend to deal
with
um trying to look over the horizon to
some new
discovery that is going to rewrite
biology or is going to lead to some
fantastic application
and what i notice is the shelf life of
many of those books was very
limited and i say that because they
they often didn't get it right it wasn't
some
you know big breakthrough that they were
thinking about and it didn't leave to
the
applications that of great interest to
people of course you read the books
and what i thought was lacking was a
book that just explained
what we do really understand about life
and in some sense
there's nothing new in my book um
i hope i explain it in a way that's
clear and i
talk about things that are interesting
but i am talking about established
principles
within which we have confidence and the
sort of books that you write
are sort of a bit more like that yeah
and i hope
as i'm sure you hope with your books
that this still can be read in 30 years
and it will still contribute to
something so yeah that was my starting
point
and the question what is life just to
return more
closely to your your um
your starting point is of course the big
problem of biology
i mean how do we distinguish between
something that is living
and something that is non-living and
i mean that's that's really um
troubled people or fascinated people
since aristotle really
and we're still addressing the question
schrodinger
um brilliant uh scientist as he was
was wrestling at a time when
some of the fundamental principles were
there but he focused only on
part of it which was essentially
speculation about the nature of heredity
hereditary
absolutely critical yeah within a few
years
of him writing the book which is 42 or
43
became much clearer with the discovery
actually at rockefeller university that
the
hereditary material was dna
deoxyribonucleic acid and then
subsequently in cambridge england that
the structure
the double helix famous watson and crick
and i'm sitting in the francis
uh crick institute with um with the
others that contributed to that rosalind
franklin and morris wilkins
um which explained because of the
brilliance of their
interpretation so simple that the double
helix
is a essentially a digital information
storage device that can copy itself
and there we hey ho we have the nature
of heredity
we don't have to worry about the second
law of thermodynamics quite so much as
um as certainly um schrodinger was
concerned about and it it is
putting together those sorts of ideas
the nature of the gene the cell and
other things as well
that leads to a picture of life
it's not a tidy um sort of dictionary
like definition
but it is a collection of attributes
that i hope
can clarify what life is and that's what
i wanted to do
to really describe ideas that we can be
sure of
you know say where they came from
because quite a few of them
actually have quite they're not that new
yeah that was what is quite shocking
they're not that new
to get a better picture of life that's
what i was aiming at
trying to do i think he did a did a
beautiful job of doing that
and i wouldn't shortchange you know the
final two chapters
do discuss ideas that are
relevant of the moment and may well
continue to be
relevant in terms of future developments
so it's both
the established and also the the
visionary side of things but i do want
to ask
do you see the question what is life as
a question that
we're really seeking the answer to or do
you see it more as a motivating
framework
i mean how important would it be to be
able to draw a line in the sand versus
using this question as kind of a guiding
principle
is it the latter or the former i think
that's a clever
question brian you've sort of got into
my
in between my ears into my brain there
really
because i set it up as this most
important question
but of course a definition of
life isn't quite as precise as we'd like
and i do
discuss the virus which sits in this
hinterland
of the living and the non-living to
almost illustrate that
but asking the question does give us a
framework
into which to think about the problems
of biology
and really that's what i'm doing with it
but
you couldn't make a title out of that
which was at all catchy
what is life with a question mark it's
certainly more
catchy i would say without a doubt
without a doubt
um so would you would you
say that in the end of the day
it's a continuum or is it discreet
between the living and the non-living i
think it is discreet
with some life forms um
such as the virus um
which do give us a problem with
discreteness
and i had a bit of a cop-out in the end
and
maybe when we talked about other things
i can go back to it
because i sort of argue it's both alive
sometimes
and dead others right i've never seen
that written down anywhere before so
that's my
one one contribution in this sort of
area it is a cop
out but it's not so stupid i mean
and um it so life is much more of a
continuum
than sometimes we think because we think
human beings sit some in some pinnacle
and really we have a lot of
relationships with the
simple little yeast that i spent my life
studying and
there's little vignettes in this book
about um my random
experimental career that did lead to
certain things that i hope
entertains yeah very enjoyable very
enjoyable every time one of those came
along
like you know really uh uh energizes the
whole discussion so it was great to
include those
well you know it's it it can get a bit
tiring just you know the grind of sort
of the textbookie type of stuff
and so i thought i would liven it up
it's all true
yeah more or less true yes
close enough yeah but i think there is a
discreetness
but what it what it demonstrates is
certain principles the
connectivity of all life we're all
related to all other life forms that's a
i mean it's a wonderful principle which
is important in our age
of trying to protect the biosphere in
the planet there are
everything around us that's living are
our relatives
i mean we have a responsibility to care
for our
relatives but not only are we related by
descent
which is what that means um we also
interact so closely with all other
living things without them
we couldn't survive we couldn't exist it
wouldn't be possible
so it is this uh being related to life
interacting with all life which is
really um
uh i wouldn't put it as a principle but
it's something we need to recognize
about about life to go back to him
with more adventurous in the sense of
trying to take on a problem
which hadn't been solved and he came up
with um
a sort of code script yeah a critical
um a a concept
but he could only talk about it in a
theoretical sort of way
and but luckily within a decade it was
essentially done yeah it was realized in
a in the most concrete
of ways um so um
among the chapters of your book you lay
out five
big ideas that allow you to
piece together an image a vision
of what life is so you talk about the
cell
gene evolution by natural selection life
as chemistry
chemistry and life as information now
for this particular audience that we
typically have watching these programs
the first three are probably relatively
familiar the cell the general structure
the gene
the information encoding molecule
evolution by natural selection
but when you come to for instance life
as
information maybe we can actually start
at the end and work our way back
what what do you mean by that well
life is information is probably the only
part of at least this section of the
book the first five ideas
which might have some controversy about
it it's not how
it's it's not what you find in the
textbooks whereas everything else
you find in the textbooks as i said i
hope i explain them in a more
interesting way than most textbooks yes
that's what they are life is information
is rather important to me and i i won't
really want to explain why
um i think that to describe what goes on
in biology we're describing the workings
of the cell
and the classical way that that's
considered
is to think about the molecules the
chemistry going on in that
cell and the physics of course
and to describe the molecular mechanisms
that are operative there
so it's a description of process
but to understand that description of
process
in biological terms nearly
always requires thinking about
information
and we've already touched upon this i'm
going to give two examples i get in the
book
the first one is dna itself now
you can do a molecular description of
dna
the beautiful double helix but we have
to escape from the beauty to think about
actually what it
means sometimes the beauty can be a bit
distracting
and actually if i ever go to an uh
another research institute with a
a piece of sculpture looking like a
double helix again i will scream
because it it just drives me crazy but
the point about the double helix is that
you are describing
in precision the position of atoms
to an angstrom um accuracy
but it is a description it has no
biological meaning
where does the biological meaning comes
from well
the biological meaning comes from a
couple of characteristics that emerge
from that structure
one is that it's made up of a
a a chain of nucleotide bases there's
four of them
a t c g um
which are in a particular order and this
of course
is just like uh computer storage what we
have there
um are four letters and um
they are arranged in a linear order and
of course
linearity of the storage of information
is
is
is something that's really rather
universal
and we see it in language we see it in
speech we are talking
in linear uh form with
words and letters that make sense and
they make sense because they have
information and that information is
conveyed
and of course in the dna structure you
have information stored
so that's the first thing and it starts
making biological sense in terms of
heredity when you've turned that
structure into information
then the second part of that is the fact
that the
double helix uh these bases only pair
with another base
so you have a a complementary it's like
a ladder and you have rungs
and and an a will only link with a t and
the g with a c
we all know this but what this means is
tear the
ladder apart then you have a template to
make an exact um
not copy a complementary copy and you
make two molecules
which are actually the same as the
original one and that is the copying
of the code that occurs every time in
fact a cell divides which is
the process that i i've studied most of
my life
and you'll see that both of these
properties are
are built around information the storage
of information
and the copying of information and the
critical thing about it is
that the the description is chemistry
the biology is interpreting that it
chemistry in terms of
information and this is of course
people have been saying this for for
ever since 1953
but stated like that it just emphasizes
the importance of information
now another example completely different
because that one's very common
is that the lac operon which is a gene
in the bacterium
which makes an enzyme which breaks down
a sugar
it doesn't matter about the details what
you have is a gene made of dna that
makes
messenger rna that makes a protein the
protein
it catalyzes reactions and then there's
a feedback from
those molecules onto the gene which uh
controls whether the gene is active or
not
once again you can describe all of this
in terms of molecular interactions
what touches what what components are
touching the
the gene the protein and so on but once
again that is only description it's not
understanding but when you put all of
that together and recognize
that actually this is a negative
feedback loop
that when you you are have the enzyme
and it's making too much of a component
and that feeds back it binds onto the
dna and switches off the gene
then once that happens you've created
created a negative feedback loop
and then it's the management of the
information because that's information
again
the information which is embedded in
that feedback loop
it becomes biological it makes sense
in terms of biology so it's the shift
from chemistry to biology
i think is centered on information and
that may be the only
i wouldn't say original thing in the
book but it is
a way of thinking about it yeah which i
think
is has some originality you know the um
it's particularly striking for me
because as you as you may know
there's been a movement in physics
to think about the fundamental
principles governing
all reality as nothing but information
laws information
mechanics you know of a different sort
you know we talk about the information
encoded in individual particles which
have an information of where they are
and how they're moving and how they're
spinning and so forth
so it is interesting that we move toward
information and one question i
i have along those lines is
there's a tendency in science to use the
most
up-to-date technology as a metaphor
for how reality works so in
your countrymen newton's time there was
the clockwork
universe because that sort of ticking
forward
quality was sort of the natural view of
the world to hold on to now in the
information age are we doing the same
thing
grabbing the latest technology and using
it as the template for
metaphorically describing the world or
do you think it goes the other way
around that
you know information truly is the deep
idea and everything else is following
from it
i think it is a deep idea but we have to
accept we do think in terms of metaphors
um
but um some of these concepts i mean
feedback controls for example
i'm much older than the computer age i
mean much much
older i mean we feedback
machines governors uh if i remember
rightly
maybe even huygens in was thinking about
this actually
in terms of windmills maybe i don't know
yeah well i might have made that up so
it's good though i like it but for sure
james watt was thinking about it with
governors on steam engines yeah we all
know that one but i think it went back
to windmills and 100 years before so the
concept
of of that of information was around a
couple hundred years ago
and if we move into the modern age
that both dna and negative feedback
control came about in the 50s and
there's no doubt
that cybernetics was uh was uh arising
there
not so which led uh in the thinking we
had touring and
the concept of computing so i think all
of these things were interlocked
so our minds were do think in these
terms
but i do think it's a fundamental
principle although
there's always this scary thing that
you're sort of halfway
saying you know that we tend to try and
explain things
in terms of things that we're
comfortable with
exactly and i mean we can't help that
we're human beings how can we
explain the world except in the terms of
what we are right and
we get into a quite difficult country
i've never understood why maths is so
important in physics in explaining
reality
i mean well the inverse square law i
look at it and i wonder about the
inverse square law
right that one we can give a good
explanation though because if think of
the lines of force spreading out on a
sphere the area of the sphere goes like
r
squared so they dilute by factor so
there are some
some things that we can give some
insight into but do you think
that the principles that you're laying
out in the book say these five
big ideas they seem to be general
on planet earth but is that a special
case i mean if there is life
out there and i know we're getting a
little bit hypothetical but the question
itself i think does still
make sense do you think that this is the
only way
that life can exist well what i did in
this book
is i i explained these five ideas which
is it is
really explaining uh basic principles
underlying all life as we see it around
us
including that tree behind you right and
you sitting in front of that tree
then what i tried to do was to derive um
some common principles that allowed us
to think
about um about life and
i came up with um with three principles
that i think
are um are important and
they uh they really are built
on um the first is that
and this wasn't my idea at all i i
i i it was well known that living things
have to be able to evolve um
it's the only way we really know that we
can produce
um purposeful behavior without having
a creator of some sort because evolution
by natural selection
allows behaviors to emerge that um
lead to purposeful consequences for the
for the whole for the organism
yeah and to produce uh
something that can evolve you have to
have an
organism that can reproduce sorry about
that
not at all amateur hour i forgot to turn
my phone off
sorry everybody i i just thought it was
support for this idea
yeah that's it someone's calling in
saying absolutely right
that's what i thought so a living thing
has to be able to reproduce
it has to have a heredity system um
which determines how that living thing
works
and that heredity system must exhibit
variability
now the these were three ideas of
hermann muller who was a
um american um geneticist in the
1950s and 60s and with those three
characteristics you will get
evolution by natural selection and that
will give you personal behavior
then we have to think well what is a
living thing then we go a bit material
they are bounded physical entities we we
have to say that because so we can
escape from computer life
you know right we'll end up in endless
discussions about computer games and
i definitely wanted to avoid that so it
involves
um physicality the simplest unit that we
can say is unambiguously
alive at least on planet earth is the
cell
yeah and that bounded nature of the cell
means you can escape the chaos of the
second law of thermodynamics because you
can have order
um at the consequence of disorder beyond
that barrier so that is the second point
and then the third one is just what
we've been talking about
living things are chemical physical
informational
machines and all of those things um
operate together they have a metabolism
they make themselves they maintain
themselves they reproduce they
act as a purposeful whole as a
consequence of evolution by natural
selection
now that's what we see in life and i've
described it like that because it has a
sort of abstraction about
it it you'll notice it didn't get into
what we normally do in saying
living things are made of protein and
dna and rna
which is the way nasa would think about
it when they go and look for life
uh somewhere else or they would look for
um of course as you know the
astrobiologists for an imbalance in the
atmospheres of
plants and so which focus on the
chemistry rather than the
principles of what life is or what you
refer to as mrs gerd or
grant mrs graham it is gren did you like
mrs grant yeah
that's what i was taught at school let's
just describe what they are
and we escape getting into principles
now
there's a couple of things that apply to
those
um principles um sorry there's a couple
of
notions i want to put on those
principles that are important for
for life on this planet and then think
about other planets so i am going to get
to your
question now take your time but the
chemistry of life that does all this
stuff
is built on carbon polymers
and we see carbon polymers um as the
basic structure of dna
and we've already talked about the
double helix and the sequence
of nucleotides and this is of course an
information device
that leads to the protein carbon polymer
and the protein carbon polymer is is
rather different
to the nucleic acid one yeah it is also
a sequence of
of of of components called amino acids
but it's more complex than dna
dna which has got four different base
nucleotides
in the case of proteins it's of course
20 different amino acids
and those amino acids have very variable
chemistries they
have some are basic some are acidic some
are bulky
some are not bulky some of these amino
acids like water some do not
and what this means is that you've
turned the rather
boring chemistry of dna which is great
for long-term informational storage
into another carbon polymer which can
fold up in a huge variety of ways
and of course the way that it happens
has been recently solved
by google deep mind which is
his wife was my graduate student
actually is that right
and we are now um exploring a
collaboration actually i have to say
addressing these problems but anyway
what i was saying is that the chemistry
is um formed by this diversity in amino
acids folding up in different ways
and why i'm stressing that is the inert
chemistry of dna is great for stable
informational storage
the complex uh chemistry of the protein
is essential for chemical action
it's the machine of life yeah so now
we've turned
information into chemistry right and
that i think is a fundamental principle
to deliver this and to get back now
to life elsewhere i don't know quite
what the chemistry will be
but i'm having a good guess that it will
be based on polymers of some sort
to encapsulate this idea of both
information
and chemistry which are i think central
to biology
yeah and i have to say when i read in
your book i mean you know i've never
studied
biology formally yeah besides high
school kind of thing
but you know i've done a lot of reading
over the years
but when you encapsulated it as these
two
flavors of polymers you know one
dedicated to having stability
and one dedicated to having chemical
activity so that the active
part is on the outside versus the versus
the inside for protein versus dna
it really clicked for me in a different
way i have to say so i really uh
appreciated well i haven't seen that
written quite like that anywhere
yeah i mean it's not that it's very
profound but it is
it is an interesting way i think to
think about it
and something which um you know a 13
year old could understand
yeah absolutely now in part of what you
just described
a little while ago you described how you
wanted to talk about these bounded
physical systems
in order to not get caught up into these
issues of computer games and life and so
forth so i guess you have
little patience perhaps for the question
that i'm gonna ask
so feel free to dismiss it at will but
consciousness is a topic
that schrodinger certainly took up in
his what his life
toward the end he kind of often kind of
went into a
an unusual place with it he brought in
vedic ideas vedic scriptures uh you know
my my brother is a
hari krishna so this interplay between
the vedas and physics is something i've
kind of lived with for decades in those
kinds of conversations so maybe
imagine you in orange i really could
actually yeah that's right
that's right i can i can perhaps join as
well i wouldn't look so good bald though
i don't think
uh i don't know but um but so stronger
had certain
you know obviously he was this deep
physicist quantum mechanics is
a lot of it's his handiwork he allowed
his mind to go to
unusual places of course but when it
comes to consciousness
what is your view because as you've been
describing things
my natural takeaway would be that the
one that i agree with that
ultimately we're just collections of
particles governed by physical laws that
manifest themselves as
chemical relationships that manifest
themselves in certain biological forms
is that it is there more well
you you'll note i did have one page
ducking the question um
because um i think it it's quite
difficult to define consciousness
i have to say let alone understand it
and i would say this is going to be one
of the great
uh questions of of humanity
for the next hundred years or more
but my position is this what you just
said that
it is an extraordinary um
development of this sort of uh
chemistry and information leads
to our neuro uh systems neuro
uh systems that control everything we're
doing including
me talking to you and out of that
emerges
um feeling conscious of
now this is spooky isn't it i mean it is
it's really spooky
and i i actually just put up the white
flag because i wanted the book to deal
with what i felt i had something
sensible to say about without having um
uh
to speculate i seem to remember our
mutual friend roger
penrose thought about consciousness and
thought it had something to do with
a structure in the cells called
microtubules
correctly some years since i've read
that and i happen to think that's
extremely unlikely um but something
about the you know the trillion whatever
it is
nerve cells that we have in and a
zillion
um connections that they make and the
electricity
the conductivity there gives rise to
me looking at you and knowing you are
brian green
and knowing that you are like me but
different and that i can talk to you and
we can make sense
and make sense of the world around us i
mean einstein said that the most
mysterious thing of course is that we
can make sense
yeah of this world right and i decided
that for this book this is the english
version of it
which is awesome can i see the cover
again look at this it's got all
the tree of life uh very nice yeah yeah
and it's got a butterfly on the back i
talk about it
oh because you talk about butterflies
when you're a kid yeah i do so
um i thought i would leave consciousness
for a bit later right right
all right so i totally i totally respect
that position but in that
um can we let the white flag down just
for one second
but uh so so
we spoke about information and
we nodded at least to the other
basic biological gadgetry within which
that information is processed in a
living system the cells the genes and so
forth
um if one is really committed to the
information
view it may lead one to the conclusion
that the substrate's not that important
ultimately if the information is
processed in the right way
then all of the qualities
including consciousness perhaps would
emerge
even without the wet wear out of you
that that
you are warm to or well
um depending quite on what you're
suggesting there
i i think it um is dependent upon
physical reality so i i
so let's imagine that we could reproduce
the information processing in a
completely different substrate
the key thing is information and the
connections
yeah and that is um that could be
completely divorced from the nature of
the chemical reality
if that's what you're saying with that i
could imagine
i don't know how it would all work i
could imagine a conscious
being which is based on a different sort
of
chemistry and i mean
what follows chemical and physical laws
but a different nature
of chemistry you know the science
fiction authors often they get they
quite like
silicon as a sort of the capacity to um
four bonds i get all that stuff and so
you know you can have these sort of
silicon
life forms but i think the information i
thought just for a moment you were going
into a completely abstract world
that one might have life forms which
were divorced from materiality
and i'd have a bit of a problem with
that detail but
as long as it's grounded in physicality
right
in physicality it could be quite
different
um and it could still work since it's
based on information
yeah we don't even have to go to
consciousness actually to say that
because i'm sort of saying that about
the simpler problem about what is living
so well the only reason to go to
consciousness is because it raises a
slightly curious question which is
i think i believe but this is not based
on
any real knowledge beyond extrapolation
from
where we've been so far i do think that
a computer
computational system if it had the right
connections
and processed information in the right
way would have the same kind of inner
sensations that
we do would be conscious now how would
you ever prove that
all very difficult questions but if one
does take that perspective which is a
very information theoretic perspective
then one comes to the possibility of a
consciousness
in a computational environment but by
your definition it wouldn't be alive so
could you have consciousness without
life
well i that ian mckeown who's a friend
of mine novelist has written a book
about
oh this one i robot that that robot i
have
not read it okay so he he takes this
full-on and addresses the question
exactly as you could imagine um about
whether you could devise
um a conscious being um
who would be behaving like us but built
in this case on
um on silicon and information
and uh it's a very very interesting
i know him and he is very interested in
science and it
it does tackle um this this problem
i i do think
that we could imagine um a life form
built on different chemical principles
which is
got information embedded in it which
would have the characteristics
of life if we now take the sort of
the touring sort of test yeah which is
really where you're you're going to
um that you could imagine it now
for the life forms that i'm thinking
about we've got to build into that also
the ability
of these systems to um reproduce
and undergo natural selection and so on
yeah and that is a bit complicated to
put into a
purely uh sort of a digital type
framework
but i do think what is good about this
is to imagine it
yeah as you are doing and as as ian
did in his novel and um to imagine it
helps us think about what actually we
are ourselves
anyway and the i i mean that the the the
you you should read this but because in
the queue and ask the question you know
uh
should you kill such a robot or is that
murder basically
and i mean just to yeah i mean it's full
of drama of course in slightly
um ludicrous sort of situations but ask
a very good question
right right absolutely so then
where do you come down and i'm not going
to dwell here so don't think that we're
going to
be off in deep philosophical land but in
your book
the word free will appears but just
before it
is seemingly or apparent i don't
remember but some qualification
of that so so clearly you were in that
space
of is it real is it not how do i square
this with everything i've
discussed in the previous chapter so
where do you come down yeah
you do like difficult questions ryan i
should have realized that before
i came on so first of all um i did use a
word like a parent
and i use a word like apparent um
because
um definitions of free will
have built within them
um the notion that there is something
the ghost in the machine
um that is um that is deciding something
outside material contingency essentially
of
dependence upon physical laws because if
it's dependent upon physical laws it's
all
all there and predetermined and so
i hedged my bets being a careful
scientist
with the word apparent because it may be
what we
think is free will is not free will
but it's important for us to believe
that we do have free will
and within the limitations of what we
are we have free will
within the societies that we built
around us so i think
the way i would start to tackle this uh
term of free will is to sort of try and
think about it in terms of our
community our society our societal
restraints within which
we have free will but we are within that
a machine i mean we're back to descartes
but
uh we're a machine that is still subject
to the physical laws because
if we try and push free will back
that far i think we're going to have
trouble with um
with physical laws in fact i agree
you know it's interesting because um i
feel that way
very strongly in the conversation i had
a few weeks ago with
frank wilceck physicist um
it came up and he was unwilling
to go as far as i or as you
he he was somehow unwilling to give up
that notion i couldn't quite get to the
core of where he was seeing free will
beyond
him saying that well we certainly feel
like we have it it's very important that
we feel like we have it which we would
all agree with but i think it's also
important to see the truth
and i think the truth is that a lot of
that at rock bottom
at least the conventional way of
thinking about free will is speaking to
something that is
illusory and i like your framing of it
in terms of how we
as a collective in a in a society in a
civilization
engage and react to one another which
does
lead to the next topic that i'd like to
spend a little time
talking about which you mentioned toward
the end of the book
which is we now have capacities
as you as you describe in the book
they're not really new capacities to
modify
the genetic makeup of a living system
but they have
gotten to a place of power
that we didn't have 20 years ago or so
crispr cash9 this capacity to go in
there and snip
out particular segments of a genome
change it replace it with something else
do you see this
how should i say it let me frame it this
way so in your book
you made a distinction a natural one
between evolution by natural selection
and intelligent design
an intelligent design was not the trial
by error approach
of evolution by natural selection rather
there was an intelligence
designing the car designing the computer
are we nothing but the mechanism by
which the universe discovers
intelligent design and are we in some
such as carrying out
the natural progression from random
change evolution by natural selection to
an intelligent version of that
emerging from that very process from the
gecko
well um sort of yes
i mean i mean we have evolved
um in this random fashion to
a a state a state of being a being in
fact
that can control
their own destiny um in the way that we
manipulate the world around us and of
course other
animal and plant life manipulates the
world around it it's it's
um its environment but we've taken that
to
several logs higher in how we
can manipulate that and how we can
design
things and now as you've rightly
um indicated we have methodologies that
means we can contemplate even designing
our fundamental code script to go back
to schrodinger's
term i mean these this ability to modify
genes very precisely again as you
rightly
said um it was not invented with crispr
cass in fact um
it was invented um in in microbes
including yeast in fact i
invented it from the yeast i work on uh
back in 1980
and that's the main reason i worked on
such a simple thing but a fantastic
revolution for crispr cats is you can do
it in everything
and very simply and indeed we now use
those techniques because they're simpler
than the ones
um that we that we devised um long ago
and the of course the the rubicon here
is modifying our own genes in precise
ways
and that in turn brings about this
notion of design
of designing ourselves and
this is something we do begin to need to
talk
very seriously about because
we as scientists can say well we now
have the technologies which are close
to um being able to say this type of
technique can be used safely we're not
actually there
yet i mean i of course i'm aware of um
what happened in china a couple of years
ago um
but that really that wasn't um
responsible
we're not yet yet there we we can do so
there's no
um feeling of error of what i'm saying
to use these techniques to change um
somatic cells which might have a cancer
or some disease
is i think perfectly acceptable it's
like a therapy you change
your egg that turns into you which
changes everything about you
or sorry every cell within you which
defines everything that is about you
is quite a different thing and
introduces the problems that perhaps you
wanted to get
to at least touch upon that we can
change our nature
our personality i mean to cure
a monogenic disease like cystic fibrosis
if we could do that i'm not sure most
people not
of course some religious people might
have an objection but
to stop that suffering with a single
disease gene that we could change
i think it's something that most people
would accept but it has to be discussed
in society to
come to decisions but to have designer
babies you know tall with blonde hair
blue eyes or whatever
is somehow a bit distasteful and then to
go further
even more distasteful i need to say
something about this though we
simply do not understand the um
genetic basis of so many of those
characteristics
to do it in any sensible way to be able
to deal with
a simple monogenic disease which are not
that many
is one thing to be able to
design perfect pitch or um
creativity of a beethoven or whatever
quite a different matter and um we are
in no position to meddle
as yet but wouldn't wouldn't i i mean i
agree but wouldn't you also
agree that it's highly likely that if we
were having this conversation
a hundred if we're still here 500 years
from now
this will be a this ship has sailed
this ship has sailed i mean it started
saving with
uh frankly with um
dna yeah and rockefeller university is
um finding out this dna
it started we now have the tools um when
we have the understanding to go with the
tools we will be able to contemplate
what you're saying
so what do we do we have to start
talking about
it and we have to start talking about it
now
before the train has gone too far down
certain tracks because now we can talk
about it
in a rational way because it's not just
over the horizon it's still quite a long
way away
and we can talk about it in an abstract
way which
where emotions can be controlled
and if we leave it too late then
we will be overcome um i think
by an inability to discuss it
in a cool way in a careful way which is
absolutely required for problems
and of this sort we must talk about it
now
and we must talk about it in a sensible
way
and we must have talked about it in a in
a
in cultures and which respect truth
and honesty and rationality and
i'm very pleased to say that the us has
now turned a corner
into a a greater possibility of of that
type
so you know i'd be fine to leave the
conversation there but if you mind like
just to push
half a step i couldn't stop you even if
i wanted
so i i i agree with with the sentiment
question a would be how do we have those
conversations and then question b is
we faced a similar type of issue with
the advent
of the atomic bomb we had let that genie
out of the bottle not with dna but with
a deep understanding
of uh fission infusion
and there was a worry back then in the
40s
that these kinds of weapons would be
used
repeatedly that would be the end of the
earth now the reason why that didn't
happen is partly because we have the
conversation
partly because there is mutually assured
destruction
and that helped people but the third
leg of the stability is it's not all
that easy
to build an atomic bomb it's not that it
not impossible and it's becoming easier
but it's not all that easy but my
understanding is
that there are kits that you can buy to
modify and it's not like you're doing it
you know in the germline
you know as you're saying but isn't it
too easy
for people to undertake these genetic
modifications for the conversations
however
positive they might be to actually stop
what's
inevitably going to happen no you're
right because i
i to bring this up because we we've got
to
accept that there's going to be
behaviors that are not entirely
um sensible and you could do this in
your garage i mean
to do it in the germ line and then
produce an embryo isn't quite as
straightforward as that it does require
um
skills but they are not skills that are
required
and resources to build an atomic bomb so
that's right
so this does emphasize the need for the
discussion now
because we will have those
rogue people who just might do it and i
mean
so in some areas of the world where
there isn't restraints
i mean this could just happen so we need
to have
frankly a sort of world discussion about
it yeah i mean
so that's the first thing i would say we
need a world discussion we need a
discussion now
we need a world discussion and we need
to devise ways of doing it
now i'm not going to try and offer you a
solution to it but i think that's
already a start
yeah um that we need that discussion and
it needs to be on a world basis and us
scientists have to really
um promote that with our political
leaders so that that
is taken on and should it be the
scientists through the political leaders
or should it be the scientists
you know taking the stage and i mean
what what is the mechanism that you
think would be most effective
well what i think about these science
sort of public issues
is the scientists are there to inform
and to explain
and then to enter into a normal
political debate
and have no special status within
that debate beyond knowing what is
possible and what is
not possible so i'm clear about that it
doesn't mean that scientists cannot
have political opinions and participate
in that debate
but they shouldn't have a special
authority
in the nature of the debate they have a
special authority
in explaining what the issues are and
explaining what is possible
and explaining what the consequences
might be and then it has to enter into a
a proper public and social debate
which has to be undertaken in rather
careful ways
not through a sort of lobbying culture
it's got to be a a rather restrained
environment for it and and it's an
interesting one
of how one would do that given that i
think it has to be on the world stage
somehow
do you think that scientists have the
skill and the inclination to
transcend the nationalistic tendencies
that usually grab hold of the
political machinery of the world
well i i think that on the whole
scientists are not
terribly strongly nationalistic so i i i
think that's
probably not the limiting
factor what i think is probably the
limiting factor is
having enough scientists who are capable
of participating
in the debate in this way with the
politicians in any sense at all
because most of us um our nose is very
close to what we do
and this requires the knowledge from
this but
in an interpretation which is much wider
and frankly there's not so many
scientists who are good at that
has the uh has the world's response
to covet 19 giving you cause for a hope
or is that
moved in the uh move the needle in the
opposite direction
well we can argue it both ways in a
sense um
i'm the optimist i think played right
this is a a return
to rationality i mean the debate about
vaccination
it is going to be a linchpin in this
yeah
and i do think we have an opportunity as
scientists to
to create a new enlightenment which
based on the principles of rational
thought and observation
and experimentation of the 18th century
which in the 18th century was confined
to a few people
we sometimes forget that yeah but most
agricultural laborers on the laborers on
the land
were not thinking much about um the
enlightenment principles but today
the bigger challenge is to have the
enlightenment principles but to though
see that within the population of the
world as a whole
and that's going to be the i think
something after kobe that we scientists
should try
and promote a discussion of how we can
create a new enlightenment built on
the the principles of rationality and
tolerance and all those good things
but this time across all the population
and not just an elitist few yeah no i uh
i second that and uh you know i know
you've had
a lot of engagement with world science
festival over the years that's certainly
one of the things that we're talking
about and one of the goals
that we set for ourselves
too one of the other things you
discussed in the book
is this interesting it's not really a
paradox
emerge and evolve you need to have death
these these phenomena
and do you think that that is a
principle that is as general
as perhaps the other three principles
that you use
to define life will we always face
mortality well i i didn't put it quite
into the same
category right so he didn't yeah and
if i can explain why and it won't
perhaps be quite the
reason that you might have thought um
it's because um without death
you can't replace one generation with
the next
and without being able to do that you
cannot evolve by natural selection
unless you have an infinite resource yes
so if
if you don't have death but you have
migration
and separation as long as the resource
is not
um limiting then you could have it you
could continue to evolve by natural
selection that's obvious but
um we it it would soon run out
of space to be able to do that at least
um
in in anything we could imagine so
that's why i didn't quite elevate it but
in
a situation where you are bounded to a
certain um
like planet earth yeah then we need
death
and it's only through death that we have
life which is the
what i sort of said i think yeah you
know in fact
that was actually the thought that i had
in mind you know there is work of course
headed toward some claim extending the
human
lifespan not just to 200 years but
perhaps
even indefinitely and then for that to
jibe with our general understanding of
life obviously you'd need
these individuals to migrate you know
and populate you know
and space goes on infinitely far so in
principle the capacity
might might be there but uh of course
that's uh
does rely upon the supposition that
these
approaches to eradicating mortality will
succeed do you think that the work
that's being done
toward that holds promise
um no um obviously it's thought to be
the case in california or at least
somehow parts of california but no i
don't i think that um
it will be possible to prolong life um
a bit um you know maybe 100 years 110
100 you know that sort of order 120
it has to be combined with a healthy
life i would say
otherwise it's not worth having yeah of
course um and that's often thought about
but when i read this notion that um
we could just be um as
as we are immortal i mean my yeast cells
are immortal in that sense
but i don't think i'd like to be a yeast
cell i'd rather be a human being
if it was only three score years and 10
than a yeast cell so
you have immortality with a single cell
organism
or you can do but i prefer this
particular conglomeration which has the
ability
to think and to talk to brian greene
well let's hope it's more than three
score a year
and ten for certain um i want to finish
that
yes right um so final
final question i just wanted to touch on
a number of places in the book you use
the
word purpose right dude when you're
talking about
the kinds of biological processes that
various
complex molecules are are crying out so
that's the purpose in the sense of
there's a very specific goal and the
structure
is aligned with reaching that goal and
it it's able to achieve
that goal of course purpose in the human
sense as we all know
has a broader connotation do you see a
link
between those well i i use the word
purpose
to actually sort of aggravate or
irritate a little bit because
you know scientists are not meant quite
to talk like that
and um get uncomfortable but um
you rightly positioned it i mean a
living thing does behave with purpose
and it responds to the environment it
moves towards where there's food it
avoids
um dangers and all of this is built
around the purpose of survival and
maintaining itself
and the word purpose is perfectly good
there yeah i
have no problem with it and um
it's it's something that can arise from
design like designing a clock as we
mentioned already in newton and the
clock um but it also can arise at random
we've already uh covered that when
and this is the reason really it becomes
a bit of a problem and i think it is a
non-problem
is exactly as you said when we think of
purpose we start wandering into
sort of notions not unlike
free will and so on and we're behaving
with a particular purpose
and that gets in the way of this um
of this description so i don't actually
see
uh that as a problem and i think life
behaving with a purpose
we we don't have to get um you know too
agitated
right at least i don't right so i said
that was the last question i
actually want to ask one more if you
don't mind so when i think back
to when i first learned the basic ideas
the weird ideas of relativity quantum
mechanics you know that's going back for
me
you know like 40 years something like
that
now i'm getting old too you know so
that's how it happens
uh and um but yet i still
am amazed by the results like if i sit
down i think about even special
relativity
after all these decades if i really
think it through it still just
blows my mind fills me with spectacular
joy
when you think about in fact we have a
little video of the working of the cell
this
this company you may know xv but there's
this beautiful uh secret life of the
cell i don't know if we can bring that
up just as a final little image here
when you think about or see
this kind of stuff happening within
cells that particles governed by the
laws of physics can come together
to carry out these kinds of crazy
wondrous processes that are
at the foundation of life
does it still fill you with that same
sense of awe
and amazement well that's an interesting
question because i have to say
when i think about relativity
or quantum mechanics like you i
i s well unlike you i struggle but
like you i am faced by
splendor the or awesome uh contribution
that humanity's made to try and
understand that
i do think that biology on the whole is
not occupying
quite the heights of that abstraction
that is always
impressive and we and that's one reason
why we tend
as a as a as as a group
to get involved in lots of description
with the hope of saying thinking well
the complexity of it all the wonder and
diversity
is is awesome and of course it is
awesome
but it's not awesome in the same way as
the ideas of physics that you were
talking about
however i do think there are principles
which aren't quite the same thing as the
animation
that we saw there wonderful as that
chemistry and physics
was there are principles which
do approach um
the wonder of the of quantum mechanics
is not in the same
territory in terms of raw intellectual
power
but in terms of understanding and making
sense of the universe
i think they are also awesome and in a
very small way i was really trying to
get somewhere towards that with this
book what is life and the principles
there
and i don't claim to have got there but
it is really
in that direction i wanted to go well i
would say you did a great job
and you did get there so again folks i
never know exactly where the camera is
but i think i'm now
in front of it what is life this is the
u.s
version paul nurse already showed us the
uk
cover it's a beautiful book explaining
these principles these ideas
with great clarity great energy
great style together with life
experiences
of one of the great thinkers of our age
so sir paul nurse thank you so much
for joining us today and everybody
should go out and buy and read
this book thank you brian great
conversation
good to see you thank you and we'll see
you hopefully sometime when the world
allows us to do that you guys are
already good
great okay good talking to you all right
folks
that was our conversation with sir paul
nurse
i'm going to take a few more questions
before
wrapping it up these can be on our
discussion
or it can be in physics anything you
want i'm not going to unfortunately last
very long for the usual reason that i
won't
excapate play what the hell does that
mean
explicate enunciate i tell my son that
all the time
enunciate um i won't be able to last
very long unfortunately but let me just
see if there are
a few things that um
might uh give us some questions to talk
about
um um
yeah here's a question about black holes
so gen z whatever that means
gen z asks what's the latest
on the tensions between quantum
mechanics
entanglement and black holes yeah it's a
very different
subject from what we're talking about
well in the way it is i mean quantum
mechanics underlies
all of the physical processes that paul
nurse and i were talking about certainly
even in that
video of the inner workings of the cell
sure you can talk at the level of the
molecules but the molecules themselves
are made of atoms the ammunitive
particles all that's governed by quantum
physics so
ultimately it is just one big quantum
system but you're right
gen z there has been some
tension i like that word good good
choice of word
between our understanding of black holes
and quantum mechanics that has emerged
in the last few decades and
the main issue that people have been
struggling with is if you have quantum
entanglement two distant particles
attached by sort of this thread like
quantum
link quantum connection what if one of
those particles falls over the edge of a
black hole and the other stays outside
do they continue to be quantum linked
together in a traditional interpretation
of einstein's ideas in general
relativity the link would persist
the edge the horizon of a black hole
doesn't do anything it's not actually a
physical thing in einstein's theory it's
a location
of no return but it's not as though
there's something there that would
disrupt the quantum entanglement between
two particles however as people
investigated that further over the last
decade or so you realize that that
answer may be too simplistic
because if you want information that
falls into a black hole to have a way of
ultimately getting out and without that
even quantum mechanics itself is
challenged so if you want information to
get out
then it turns out that you need not only
entanglement between a particle
on the outside and inside a black hole
but you need entanglement between the
particles on the outside among
themselves that's where the information
would be stored in the correlations in
those
quantum connections and you cannot have
a situation
where particle a is entangled with
particle b which is entangled with
particle c inside the black hole you can
have that triple
maximal entanglement so something has
got to give
so either the entanglement across the
horizon of the black hole snaps
which would release energy which is
where this notion of a
black hole event horizon as a fire wall
a
wall of energy comes from or maybe
information doesn't get out
or maybe our basic understanding of
the physics is just missing something
essential
and that's where the problem arises
so if you ask me what's the view today
most people at least that come at this
from
the particle physics string theory
perspective are not willing to accept
that information is lost
okay so that solution goes out the
window
and some are willing to accept the
possibility of a firewall but some have
even suggested more exotic
circumstances where the information
could get out maybe even through
wormholes connecting outside and
inside so it's up in the air i would say
it's not exactly
a done deal as of today but yes it is a
deep and important
question having to do with quantum
mechanics
and space time itself ultimately comes
down to trying to understand
general relativity in quantum mechanics
that essential conundrum that has driven
physics for
many many decades all right i'm going to
wrap it up there i'm a little
uncomfortable after sitting for two
hours
or so so we will pick this up again
at some point perhaps two weeks from now
you will note
again sir paul nurse was on the list of
names that we extracted from your
suggestions so we do listen
to what you guys say in terms of who
you'd like to be part of these
conversations so continue
to make those suggestions we will
continue to look at them and try
to choose future guests from
that list as we go forward
okay guys that's about it please check
out
sir paul nurse's book it's a wonderful
read
keep an eye out for the next of these
conversations going forward
and until then take care
[Music]
do
[Music]
you